this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream a subscription streaming
service that offers
thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles right now for a
limited time you guys can get 25
off the cost of a subscription more on
them in a bit
it's one of the deadliest substances
known to man ricin is a poison so toxic
that a mere three
milligrams about one tenth of a
teaspoon's worth
is enough to kill a human odorless and
tasteless once refined
it can be easily slipped into food or
water or even aerosolized and
inhaled into the lungs in its purest
form it's thought the amount obtained
from a single castor bean
could end a thousand lives yet it's not
the potency
of ricin that makes it such a nightmare
or even
the lack of antidotes no it's how
damn easy it is to make naturally
occurring in the seeds of the cast of
beans ricin can be cooked up by anyone
with access to a coffee grinder
and some basic chemistry knowledge as a
result it has long been one of the most
tempting substances for poisoners
bioterrorists and governments looking to
cause carnage
used as a weapon since prehistory today
we're telling the story
of ricin nature's perfect poison
in terms of common household objects
that are secretly nightmare murder
machines
you couldn't get much more nightmarish
or more murderous
than rycinious communists the scientific
name for the castor bean plant ricinia's
communist grows across the world
cropping up naturally in tropical
climates
it also crops up in a whole lot of
american gardens where it's valued for
its easy growing and pretty colors and
that's something
of a mine because it also creates one of
the deadliest poisons known to man
found inside the seeds of the castor
bean plant ricin is to poison is what
the bfg
was to the doom franchise the ultimate
shortcut
for just super killing everyone as a
toxin ricin latches onto cells and stops
them from making proteins
this means affected cells die on mass
leading to all sorts of horrible side
effects for the animal they're a part of
and
eventually leading to the ultimate side
effect death
currently there's no known antidote
nothing doctors can do for you but try
to alleviate your symptoms
cross their fingers and hope for the
best since eating as few as
two castor beans could get enough ricin
into your system to kill you
this is just a bit more than a little
terrifying
but the good news is that accidental
ricin poisoning is
relatively rare rather than coating the
seeds ricin is found by pulping castor
beans and
separating out the different chemicals
typically this is when castor beans are
mashed for producing castor oil a
process that happens on a grand scale
each year without ever killing
anyone that means simply swallowing a
cast of bean almost certainly
won't kill you which is great news for
negligent parents with toddlers
determined to
eat just about everything rather it's
chewing the seed that releases the ricin
and makes it deadly down in latin
america where castor beans are painted
and made into jewelry
this occasionally results in teenagers
who choke on their bracelets getting
hospitalized
really though the chances of you
unintentionally killing yourself with
ricin
are vanishingly small it's when someone
wants to deliberately poison you
that things get terrifying ricin is
painfully easy to make at home
while anyone wanting to kill someone
with anthrax is going to have to first
locate the spores then get an advanced
degree in microbiology
to learn how to weaponize them any
would-be rice and poisoner just needs to
nip to the store and buy some castor
beans and a few other common products
after mashing the beans and their coffee
grinder the only step to getting a
deadly poison is mastering
chromatography a
process any chemistry undergrad could
talk you through
and no obviously we're not going to go
into any more detail than that
this is meant to be a piece of
infotainment not
exhibit a and some future federal
prosecution
thank you very much okay so we've seen
how terrifyingly easy it is for someone
to make ricin the obvious question is
what would happen if they poisoned you
with it if you've got a weak stomach you
should probably look away about now
because answering that question is where
things
are gonna get really icky
according to the centers for disease
control there are three ways
that you can be poisoned with ricin
ingesting it being injected with it
and inhaling it while each is about as
fun as a porcupine enema
the specifics of their spiky embraces
are wildly different
let's start with the most obvious way of
getting it into your system
ingesting it of all cases of ricin
poisoning this is by far the most common
it may be also the least pleasant within
a few hours of being poisoned or just
stupidly chewing on some caster beans
you'd
start to feel nauseous this would be
followed by extreme abdominal cramps
then vomiting them bloody diarrhea
inside your gut the ricin would be
attacking the cells killing them causing
them to die in a microscopic genocide
but the damage wouldn't stop there as
the poison spread into your bloodstream
other organs would be affected
liver failure kidney failure even
failure of your central nervous system
are
all possibilities while accidental rice
and ingestion only results in death
around six percent of the time
this would still be a roller coaster of
pain but if anyone really wanted to kill
you
they'd probably use the next method
injection for assassin's injection has
long been the favored method of rice and
delivery with good reason
unlike ingesting ricin injecting it
doesn't quickly lead to cramps and
projectile vomiting likely the first
thing you'd notice is pain around the
puncture wound as the ricin attacks the
muscle itself causing necrosis of the
flesh a
phase would really advise you against
googling
within five hours general weakness and
dizziness would overcome you but it
wouldn't be until approximately half a
day had passed that the symptoms really
hit
after that your body would become a raft
tossed around in a storm of fever
headaches vomiting and falling blood
pressure for about one in five people
this storm eventually abates for 83
percent of injection victims though
it ends in multiple organ failure and
death
yet it's the last type of ricin exposure
that really scares people
in biodefense that's because inhaled
ricin
could only come from a terrorist attack
in contrast to swallowing or being
injected with rice and inhaling the
poison won't lead to multiple organ
failure instead the ricin will settle
into and attack your lungs with
single-minded deficiency
destroying them as surely as if you'd
inhaled napalm within hours you'd feel
pain in your chest to develop a
cough and flu-like symptoms your lungs
would fill with fluid making it
impossible to breathe your blood
pressure
would drop by the time a day had passed
you'd almost certainly be dead
we say almost certainly because there's
literally zero cases in record of people
dying
after inhaling ricin experiments have
been done on animals but as far as we
know
no human has ever got ricin in their
lungs and this brings us to one of the
few bits of good news about this deadly
poison
it really sucks for use in mass casualty
attacks
while purified ricin from a single
caster beam could theoretically kill a
thousand people
it's simply not cost effective at such a
scale
put it this way if you wanted to blanket
a hundred square kilometer area with an
aerosolized pathogen
you would need just a kilogram of
anthrax by contrast you'd have to source
four tons of ricin and pro tip here
buying four tons of castor beans is
absolutely going to land you on an fbi
watch list
yet just because ricin isn't cost
effective at scale doesn't mean it isn't
a tempting weapon
since prehistoric times a whole lot of
people have used it to kill a whole lot
of their enemies in the most
grotesque ways imaginable
on the border between south africa and
eastwatini liza cave
was the deeply unimaginative name of
border cave
but while its name might be boring the
same can't be said for its contents one
of the best preserved archaeological
sites bought a cave
has yielded unique artifacts from 200
millennia of human history
in the context of today's video though
it's mainly interesting for a specific
discovery one dating back to around
22 000 bc a discovery which suggests
humans have been poisoning one another
with ricin
since the dawn of time the object in
question is
a notched wooden stick when it was first
discovered in the 1970s it was thought
to just be some cool old stick from
history times but when a chemical
analysis was run in the 2010s
it was discovered that the stick had
traces of ricin on it it's now thought
ancient tribes used this stick to coat
their arrowheads in the poison an
ancient form of ricin injection chilling
as the thought is maybe it's
not surprising to know our ancestors
would seek to turn the humble caster
bean
into some kind of weapon after all
that's exactly what countless modern
governments have tried to do
back in 1888 peter herman stillmark
became the first person in history to
successfully extract
and isolate ricin prior to this the
toxin had been mainly used by poisonous
but now it was possible to skip
slipping someone cast a bean mulch and
go straight to ricin
people suddenly got very interested
there was a problem because by now the
castor bean plant
was everywhere not long before castor
oil had been found to make a great
lubricant for train engines massively
increasing their efficiency that meant a
global optic and cultivation of
rycinious communists so when news of
stillmark's discovery broke
governments were all like wait these
super common plants we've got lying
around could be used to make a weapon
and none of our enemies have done it
first
the first major push to turn ricin into
a bioweapon came during world war one
with bocion taunt and central powers
already lobbing poison gas at one
another
scientists at the american university
experimental station began figuring out
how to take things to the next level one
major focus of their research
was ricin the american plans for the
toxin took two distinct forms
the first was to find a way to coat
bullets in it to increase their
lethality the modern equivalent of
those ancient tribes dipping their
arrowheads in the poison the only
trouble was that ryzen can be destroyed
by high temperatures
meaning firing those bullets would
render them useless so the u.s turned to
another method
creating a deadly dust cloud remember
earlier when we said inhaling ricin was
a really nasty way to go well america
wanted to inflict that on central power
soldiers on a
vast scale the idea was that ricin would
be refined to an
ultra fine powder then spread in the air
over battlefields the only reason rice
and dust isn't now as associated with
world war one as mustard gas is that the
military got cold feet
when it became clear that there was no
antidote before anyone could convince
them to go ahead
the war came to an end in the flurry of
international conventions that followed
ricin was outlawed alongside other bio
and chemical agents
so i guess that's it right after world
war one all nations respectfully abided
by these treaties and no governments
ever
again did anything evil with ricin well
you're in for a bit of a shock if that's
what you believe as we're about to see
the 20th century would be full of states
trying to use ricin as a weapon sadly
some of them would even succeed coming
up next more terrifying stories of ricin
in modern history but first
here's a quick word from today's sponsor
curiositystream curiositystream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles
for some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals think of
it as the netflix for nerds or
the hulu the history buffs curiosity
stream is available on many platforms
and web apps including roku
android xbox one smart tvs ios
chromecast amazon fire amazon kindle and
apple tv
it's pretty much everywhere it's also
available everywhere in the world and
it's constantly updated with awesome
timely content
for example this spring they added a
documentary called secret nazi weapons
based on the requests i see in the
comments section of these videos i'm
guessing
you guys are probably gonna like that
one but
if you're enjoying today's video on the
super terrifying topic of verizon maybe
you'll
enjoy curiosity streams three-part
series
pain pus and poison it's great it's
terrifying
it's a mini-series you can go to
curiositystream.com biographics for
unlimited access the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series
and right now use the promo code
biographics to save 25
off the cost of an annual subscription
which comes out to only 14.99
for the whole year again
curiositystream.com
forward slash biographics 25 off 14.99
for the whole year
and let's get back to the ricin
chronicles
it was september 7th 1978 when georgie
markov left his job at the bbc world
service in london
and headed toward waterloo bridge a
bulgarian playwright and satirist markov
had once been close to the country's
communist leadership before
defecting at the height of the cold war
now he lived in england from where he
broadcast scathing takedowns of the
bulgarian regime it was dangerous work
already markov had survived two
assassination attempts
not was he the only one just a fortnight
earlier fellow bulgarian dissident
vladimir kostav had been
hospitalized in paris with a mysterious
sickness that nearly killed him but if
markov was on the lookout for assassins
that balmy fall day
it's doubtful he could have prepared
himself for what came next
as he was waiting at a bus stop the
playwright felt a sharp pain in his leg
turning around he saw a man with an
umbrella mutter an apology and get into
a cab
it was a minor incident one that could
have been easily forgotten it was also
the moment
that markov's fate was sealed that same
night markov began to suffer muscle
cramps and fever the spot on his leg
where the guy bumped him with the
umbrella was in pain
he felt weak dizzy the very next day
georgie markov was hospitalized
unable to figure out what was wrong with
him doctors initially assumed he was
suffering from a weird infection but
since you've watched this far you can
already guess what was really going on
that man at the bus stop had been
working for the bulgarian secret police
his umbrella had been
a weapon designed in collaboration with
the kgb one capable of firing a tiny
pellet out of its tip
and deep into a victim's flesh and we
mean tiny the pellet now lodged in
markov was barely 1.5 millimeters in
diameter
so small you'd assume it was incapable
of causing damage
were it not for the tiny hole in its
surface a hole
that held a couple of milligrams of
purified ricin sealed with wax designed
to melt after it entered a human body
minutes after being injected into markov
that pellet had released its deadly load
and now there was nothing that could be
done when markov died of ricin poisoning
on september 11th
aged 49 doctors didn't even know it was
ricin that had killed him it wasn't
until an autopsy uncovered the pellet
that it became clear that scotland yard
was dealing with an assassination
even then the truth of markov's death
wasn't confirmed until the early 1990s
when communism had finally collapsed in
eastern europe today markov's murder
remains the most high profile instance
of
rice and poisoning in history yet he was
far from the only one to suffer this
fate
in the cold war that other bulgarian in
paris the one who'd got mysteriously
sick just two weeks before markov
well after markov died doctors went back
and examined a small puncture wound on
his back
inside they found an identical metal
pellet it was only by sheer fluke that
the rice and dose and kostov's pellet
had been just under the lethal limit yet
it wasn't just the bulgarians who were
messing around with rice in those years
in 1981 communist polish agent and cia
asset boris korsak was
shopping in a store in virginia and he
felt a sharp pain above his kidney
within hours he felt deathly with
similar symptoms to markov
luckily unlike markov he somehow
survived
after these three assassination attempts
ryzen slipped up the menu for killing
dissidents replaced with
more exotic agents like polonium or
novichok
but even as governments were beginning
to turn their backs on the toxin another
scarier type of group was getting very
interested in it
it's time we met the ricin terrorists
although it had been first mooted back
in world war one no one took serious
steps to create inhalable rice and
powder
until the second world war in 1944 the
u.s began to experiment with rice and
dust at utah's dugway proving ground
where it was known as agent w the test
got pretty far by spring a form of agent
w that could be ground down to an
ultrafine powder was all ready to go the
scientists hoped it could be sprayed out
of planes over germany but it wasn't
before long that the americans ran
slap into the major problem that rice
imposes as a military weapon
there are simply far more cost-effective
toxins out there so they abandoned their
research
just as the british and french would
abandon theirs just as iraq in the 1980s
would
give up its plan to create ricin bombs
yet all this research
firmly established one unalterable fact
powdered ricin that could be breathed in
was super deadly it might not be useful
for killing hundreds in one go but if
you set your sights a little
lower if your main goal was to cause
mass panic with
deaths as a bonus well suddenly
inhalable ricin
was looking very tempting the first to
try and jump on this bandwagon were
america's far-right extremists in 1991
the feds busted a plot to kill u.s
marshals with rice in
either absorbed through the skin or
inhaled four anti-government plotters
went down
across the next decade several more
militia group members were arrested for
either owning or trying to make ricin
but it wouldn't be until the 21st
century that ryzen really exploded
into american nightmares on october 15
2003 alarms went off at a south carolina
mail processing facility just two years
earlier in the fall of 2001 anthrax
laced letters had paralyzed the u.s
postal system
sickening 17 people and killing five in
the aftermath of the amerithrax attacks
the u.s had invested colossal sums in
screening mail
for biological contaminants and now that
investment was paying off
that day a letter was isolated at the
south carolina facility
inside was a small metal vial and two
typewritten notes
the first one helpfully declared caution
rice and poison enclosed in sealed
container
do not open without proper protection
the second state of the attack is demand
calling him or herself fallen angel they
promised to turn dc
into a ghost town unless that is the
government repealed
new interstate trucking laws wait so
hold on a minute yup it turns out that
the first rice and letter attack in u.s
history was by someone majorly pissed
off with minor changes to federal
trucking regulations
and we mean really minor the one that
most concerned fallen angel was a
two-hour increase in
legally allotted sleep time for long
distance drivers and it's here that we
get to one of the oddest aspects of
ricin because
it's so easy to manufacture it doesn't
just attract governments terrorists and
wall to white it also attracts
fruitcakes loonies and weirdos people
who if they tried to make a bomb would
probably blow their own hands off but
who are still capable of schlubbing to
the store and buying some cast
beans in a pack of envelopes but while
this ease of production increases the
chance of idiots getting involved in
bioterrorism it also means
rice and letters are way less of a
problem than those containing anthrax
a few days after the south carolina
letter another rice and envelope for
fallen angel was found in a white house
male processing facility months later in
february 2004 ricin powder from a
suspected burst envelope was found at an
office building on capitol hill
terrifying as this must have been for
the staff issued to be decontaminated
that was the end of it there were no
more letters from fallen angel no
attempts to turn
dc into a ghost town the trucking
regulations that had
inspired the attack were never repealed
in the end the 2003 rice and letters had
sickened no one
changed nothing and killed nobody still
that wouldn't stop others from trying
again
in the very near future
it's not often that the tale of a deadly
toxin turns into
absurdist comedy but that's what's about
to happen here
because there's simply no way we can
tell the story of the 2013 ryzen letters
without it sounding goofy as hell
despite being perhaps the dumbest series
of bio-terror attacks ever perpetrated
the story of the 2013 letters started
off fairly dark
on april 15th the letter addressed gop
senator roger wicker set off alarms at
the capitol when it tested positive
horizon
the news broke the same damn day two
pressure cooker bombs exploded at the
boston marathon raising the specter of a
coordinated series of attacks
when another letter this one addressed
to barack obama tested positive two days
later
it seemed like a terrorist cell might be
out to cause carnage in america
but then things started to get strange
down in mississippi a local judge also
received ryerson letter
an unlikely target for any international
terrorists
then there were the letters themselves
each ended with the phrase
i am kc and i approve this message
where the feds did some googling it
turns out iamkc and i approve this
message was the sign-off used by a small
town elvis impersonator
paul kevin curtis it gets crazier than
that though despite arresting curtis the
fbi quickly figured out that he hadn't
mailed the ricin instead a local karate
instructor with a grudge against
curtis's success on the elvis circuit
had sent the letters to frame him for
terrorism
and yes that is a real sentence that i
just had to say
james everett dutcher was arrested
shortly after trying to dispose of a
coffee grinder that tested positive
horizon he went down for 25 years
he later emerged that the thing that
pushed him over the edge was curtis
falsely claiming to be a member of mensa
weirdly
dushka wasn't the only lunatic sending
rice in that spring one month later
another batch of contaminated letters
were intercepted on the way to obama
these were traced back to shannon
richardson a
bipart actress who'd been in the walking
dead and the vampire diaries but rather
than turning bio-terrorists she'd sent
them to frame
her hated ex-husband as one newspaper
dryly noted today a marital spat
developed into a full-blown
bio-terrorist attack on the white house
see what we mean about bryson attracting
fruitcakes in the years since the 2013
clownfest rice and powder has popped up
occasionally on the news sometimes in
scarier contexts and
sometimes sillier ones at the scarier
end you have the 2018 cologne plot that
saw an isis-inspired terrorist arrested
with both bombs and
enough ricin to kill dozens at the less
freaky end you have the quebec woman who
tried to mail rice into donald trump in
because she wanted him to drop out of
the presidential race needless to say
that letter didn't get anywhere near the
president
today then despite its extreme toxicity
ricin is most often associated with
lonely weirdos who have watched too much
breaking bad
weirdos with a grudge or a craving for
attention
in some cases both certainly of all the
bioterror attacks it's been used in
inside the usa ricin has performed
miserably killing a
grand total of no one but while it might
be tempting to write the toxin off as
little more than a joke
to do so would be foolish there's good
reason communist agents used ryson for
assassinations a good reason why
militaries are drawn to it a
good reason why our african ancestors
dipped their arrows in it
tens of thousands of years ago lest we
forget ricin is one of the most
perfect poisons known to man a toxin
with no antidote that leaves
little trace after killing you sure it
makes a crappy bio weapon in the hands
of
idiot karaoke instructors but get it in
the hands of someone who knows what
they're doing
and you'll see just how deadly it can be
perhaps the last word on this subject
should come from
anthony fauci who opened an envelope in
mid-2020 to find himself covered
in mysterious white powder it had to be
one of three things the doctor remarked
a hoax or anthrax which meant i'd have
to go on cipro for a month
or if it was ricin i was dead say
bye-bye so i really hope you enjoyed
this
absolutely horrifying video thank you to
curiositystream for sponsoring it if you
did enjoy it please
do leave us a thumbs up below don't
forget to subscribe
and thank you for watching
you